man I mean my first apartment rent was
235 dollars a month
you can't even what you'd have to get
nine roommates to do that you can't
cross the threshold for that that's
unbelievable they won't even let you go
look at an apartment yeah you know but
that but it didn't matter in those days
my pay was different
and guess what the overall the cost of
goods was different gasoline was a buck
26 okay when that rent was there so it's
all relative in Russia and ratios and so
um not picking on you and giving the old
Boomer line here you just don't
understand youngin but you just don't
understand young and it's always been
this way
it's always been high yeah and you
always have to make a decision to say no
so later you can say yes live like no
one else so that later you can live and
give like no one else